we actually filmed this in 1981 and then
we worked on it for nine months that
took us into 1982 we finished it in 1982
and then I went in was released in 1983
as a major motion picture after playing
for 617 performances on PBS am i close
no you're off by a year okay did so we
started we we actually shot it in 82 no
we started in 80 80 there you go yeah
Mac D but it needs to say the journey
that has all of you sitting here is is
really an experience that I have to say
thank you to Mach day for being the
producer and really developing this
piece of work this level and the genius
of him was to allow me to be the
producer because at that moment that
moment in time I could tell you right
now he came to me and he asked me to do
two films for him he asked me to do the
talent not with a pistol in his hand and
the Milagro Beanfield war but the only
way I could do the Milagro Beanfield war
was to do the with the pistol in his
hand so but he said the key ingredient
he said who would you like to have
direct you in this movie and my life
changed for the rest of my life to this
day I had known Bob young for since 1975
and we did one film together before this
and amazing amazing aesthetic that you
will see in this film that changes the
course of film very few people really
understand the aesthetic it's easy to
pronounce it's easy to say but almost
impossible to do it correctly
and there's been very few people that
have been able to really comprehend and
use it and so the best thing I ever did
was asking Bob to read The Ballad of
Gregorio Cortez and ladies and gentlemen
this is truly the man who gave us this
story
the total intent of the piece and the
understanding of what it is to really
make a piece of work that not only lasts
for a hundred years but is hailed by the
United States Historical Society as the
most authentic Western ever made in in
film history you're about to see it
I did do my homework when when when
Eddie said I want Robert Young to direct
me I did look at his movies and I did
see Alan barista which is an astonishing
movie and I did see nothing but a man
which is a profound movie and I knew
that Edward James Olmos was not only a
brilliant actor but he actually had some
good sense